[Applauso]
[Musica]
quando ero uno studente di scuola
superiore
suonavo la chitarra in un gruppo
musicale era una cosa tra amici in
piccolo niente di niente di speciale
abbiamo suonato al di fuori della nostra
sala prove solo un paio di volte ci
siamo lasciati abbiamo smesso di suonare
con l'avvicinarsi degli esami di stato
qualche tempo dopo ricevetti un
messaggio dal nostro batterista che mi
informava della morte del padre
dell'altro chitarrista che suonavano
insieme a noi
ricordo che tutti noi membri del gruppo
eravamo abbastanza sconvolte ovviamente
ma anche molto sorpresi perché fino a
qualche tempo prima era proprio lui ad
accompagnare il figlio alle prove
installa bene
scopriamo successivamente che era stato
colpito da un tumore al pancreas che lo
portò via del giro di brevissimo tempo
io non posso che immaginarmi la
sensazione di terrore di impotenza che è
quella famiglia ha dovuto sopportare
al momento della diagnosi per tanti
tumori oggi le probabilità di guarigione
sono ottime ma ancora in ogni caso non è
mai un percorso semplice la
chemioterapia è dura durissima e
comporta tremendi effetti collaterali
d'altonde un farmaco chemioterapico e
progettato con uno scopo ben preciso che
uccidere delle cellule
ma come possiamo fare
a rendere questo farmaco selettivo verso
le cellule malate evitando che vada a
colpire le cellule sane
in molti casi la semplice assunzione
orale o endovenosa non è sufficiente
perché perché e come spedire una lettera
senza scrivere il destinatario il nostro
fanno che potrebbe finire concentrato
nel fegato potrebbe andare in giro per
il nostro corpo dove non lo vorremmo
potrebbe addirittura essere attaccato
dal nostro sistema immunitario o da
altre proteine e quindi non arrivare
proprio dove dovrebbe ci sono tante
strategie che noi chimici noi
ricercatori stiamo impiegando per
cercare di risolvere questo problema è
una di queste è quella che potremmo
definire la strategia del cavallo di
[ __ ] linea di base è abbastanza
semplice
ricopriamo questo farmaco da uno
speciale rivestimento che in qualche
modo gli permette di essere protetto
dall'ambiente esterno da una parte e di
arrivare intero al tumore e di essere
rilasciato riprendendo un'espressione di
paul ehrlich premio nobel per la
medicina nel 1908 quello che ci
servirebbe un proiettile magico che
abbia la capacità di colpire esattamente
il bersaglio che vogliamo ma non tutto
il resto ovviamente manco a dirlo è più
semplice a dirsi che a farsi però ci si
lavora ma quindi come facciamo a
proteggere il nostro il nostro farmaco
come facciamo a costruire questo cavallo
di [ __ ] per farlo godiamo un pochino
cambiare prospettiva siamo abituati a
pensare alla chimica come alla scienza
delle reazioni
abbiamo una molecola una molecola b
delle molecole ok degli atomi dei legami
questi legami si rompano gli atomi si
riorganizzano e otteniamo una molecola c
diversa da quelle di partenza
in effetti un chimico è un ottimo
artigiano
col area a sua disposizione una cassetta
degli attrezzi piena di reazioni
chimiche piena di trasformazioni che gli
permettono a partire da molecole molto
semplici di disegnare di sintetizzare
anche molecole estremamente complesse ma
riprenda riprendendo la nostra nostro
paragone è un po come tagliare degli
alberi e trasformarli in delle assi di
legno ma poi come faccio dalle assi di
legno a passare al cavallo
ovvero come faccio dalle molecole a
ottenere un architettura molecolare come
faccio a fare in modo che queste
molecole si dispongono a formare il
guscio che a me interesserebbe dobbiamo
cambiare prospettiva ovvero non
considerare più le molecole come il
nostro punto di arrivo ma al contrario
come il nostro punto di partenza
ora uno scienziato non è che un alunno
un alunno della natura in particolare e
alla natura si ispira quando ha bisogno
di trovare la soluzione ai problemi che
ci si pongono davanti quindi dov'è che
in natura
troviamo una qualche specie di membrana
che separa che protegge l'interno
dall'esterno ma non una membrana come un
muro di cemento impenetrabile ma al
contrario qualcosa di intelligente che
sia capace di riconoscere l'ambiente
esterno non c'è bisogno di andare molto
montani basta pensare alla membrana
cellulare la membrana cellulare e una
struttura estremamente complessa che non
si limita semplicemente a delimitare uno
spazio ma al contrario a una miriade di
funzioni funzionale per esempio come
dogana regolando il traffico delle
molecole dall'interno e dall'esterno
all'interno della cellula e viceversa
funziona un po anche da ambasciatore
permette alla cellula di comunicare con
l'esterno di ricevere le informazioni
che provengono dal resto del nostro
corpo
ora il problema però è sempre
adesso come faccio a ricreare il
laboratorio qualcosa che assomigli a una
membrana cellulare
beh voglio raccontarvelo partendo da un
concetto apparentemente scollegato
ovvero il sapone
quando abbiamo le mani sporche di grasso
sappiamo che lavarle con l'acqua
corrente non è sufficiente
non è sufficiente perché le sostanze
oleose non sono solubili in acqua
in effetti pensiamo all'olio d'oliva se
mettiamo dell'olio d'oliva in acqua si
separa e galleggia in superficie
come mai in generale possiamo
distinguere tutte le molecole in due
grandi categorie le molecole idrofile
che sono affini all'acqua come lo
zucchero per esempio o il sale da cucina
e poi abbiamo delle molecole che invece
sono l'ipo file o verso la fine e grassi
come per esempio la benzina o il
petrolio e il sapone cosa centra il
sapone si comporta un poco a una specie
di mediatore culturale è formato da una
lunga coda di atomi di carbonio lipofila
e da una testa idrofila nel momento in
cui ci laviamo le mani con acqua e
sapone quello che succede che la
gocciolina di grasso viene stabilizzata
perché le code dalla nostra molecola di
sapone che sono lì può file possono
entrare penetrare all'interno della
gocciolina di grasso mentre la testa
rimane in superficie a contatto con
l'ambiente acquoso che gli è più
congeniale
in questa maniera è come se è la
gocciolina di grasso fosse mascherata
dall acqua nascosta e questo ovviamente
la stabilizza con qualche piccolo
trucchetto del mestiere è possibile fare
in modo che invece ottenere un singolo
strato possiamo tenerne 2
in questa maniera vedete abbiamo una
specie di membrana formata dalle code
intrecciare tra di loro
quindi sempre uno spazio grasso mentre
all'esterno e all'interno abbiamo sempre
uno strato acqua
ecco vedete ora ho ottenuto qualcosa che
in qualche maniera assomiglia alla mia
membrana cellulare
beh posso utilizzarlo allora posso
immaginare di metterci al leader
all'interno il mio farmaco
d'ora in poi chiameremo queste speciali
capsule con loro termine tecnico ovvero
liposoma l'idea quindi è che a questo
punto la mia molecole il mio fermo che
finalmente protetto dall esterno
il nostro organismo vede questi liposomi
come se fossero delle cellule e quindi
non li attacca proteggi la mia molecola
ma ora questa e metà del lavoro come
faccia fuori in modo che questo liposoma
con la sua col suo carico finisca dove
deve andare all'interno del tumore e non
nei tessuti sani e soprattutto una volta
arrivato lì come fa a rilasciare quello
che c'è all'interno per farlo possiamo
sfruttare l'ingordigia del tumore un
tumore e in un certo senso un po come un
ladro un ladro affamato goloso che ha
bisogno di una quantità immensa di cibo
di nutrimento questo vuole dire ha
bisogno di sangue
e come fa ottenere tutto questo sangue
può secernere delle molecole che
permettono la crescita di nuovi vasi
sanguigni
questi nuovi vasi usano i piccoli vasi
crescono velocemente e come ogni il
lavoro fatto di fretta è un lavoro fatto
male di conseguenza mentre i vasi
sanguigni sani sono formati da uno
strato di cellule strettamente connesse
tra di loro
quando invece ci ritroviamo in un vaso
di un tessuto tumorale
queste cellule sono malate sono separate
tra di loro
ecco abbiamo trovato una differenza
questa differenza è fondamentale perché
perché i nostri liposomi sono troppo
grandi per passare attraverso le pareti
dei vasi sanguigni normali ma sono
piccoli abbastanza per passare
attraverso i pori dei vasi malati
sfruttando quindi questa piccola ma
significativa differenza
la possiamo fare in modo che le nostre
particelle i nostri liposomi arrivino
solamente nel tessuto tumorale
ora come faccio a fare in modo però che
si rompano il rilascino il loro carico
di nuovo
possiamo sfruttare questa particolarità
dei tumori di crescere velocemente
immaginate di essere a una festa ma non
una festa di persone educate tranquille
ma una festa di ubriaconi quindi lattine
di birra ovunque cartoni della pizza
vomito quella una puzza pestilenziale
beh l'idea è più o meno la stessa
l'ambiente tumorale ci assomigliamo ter
pieno di scarti e ricco di scarti per
questo motivo il ph all'interno degli
studi molto morali e leggermente
leggermente più basso rispetto al ph dei
tessuti sani
ecco un'altra differenza che possiamo
sfruttare il nostro vantaggio
se io sfrutto questa piccola differenza
di ph posso andare a sintetizzare delle
molecole che magari sono degradabili si
possono rompere spezzare a quel ph
ed ecco allora che posso creare il mio
liposoma in modo che a ph leggermente
acido si possa rompere e rilasciare il
carico che all'interno
questa è una delle strategie possiamo a
costarne altre per esempio potremmo fare
in modo di utilizzare una specie di
meccanismo a chiave e serratura una
specie di forziere come sapete tutte le
celle comunicano con le altre comunicano
con l'esterno lo fanno attraverso delle
proteine che interagiscono con delle
altre proteine che sono in circolo
appunto attraverso un meccanismo a
chiave e serratura una chiave può
entrare solo in una specifica serratura
se io faccio in modo da trovare la
chiave giusta contenuta solo nelle
cellule tumorali
posso immaginare di creare una serratura
da mettere nel mio liposoma che si possa
aprire solamente quando si trova in un
tessuto malato
e inutile dirlo ovviamente siamo ancora
molto indietro
quelle che vi sto presentando sono delle
idee sono delle ricerche che noi chimici
stiamo portando avanti ormai da un po di
tempo stiamo facendo tanti progressi ma
ancora siamo ben lontani dall'avere a
nostra disposizione una soluzione finale
definitiva a volte il nostro proiettile
magico si apre troppo presto a volte
esplode troppo tardi a volte non esplode
proprio a volte esplode nel posto
sbagliato
in generale non è un lavoro facile
la mia speranza è che un giorno nessuno
debba più sentire quella sensazione di
impotenza e di disagio che deve aver
provato quella famiglia quando ho
ricevuto quella terribile diagnosi
la mia speranza è che un giorno una
speranza ci sia per tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]